[Musique]
et alan à tous on me pose souvent cette
question comment m'est venue cette
passion pour l'océan et pourquoi les
cétacés
alors moi même je n'ai pas vraiment la
réponse je pense tout simplement que ça
a été la succession d'un tas de
rencontres de personne inspirante autour
de moi car vous vous l'avouer rien de
naturel que cette passion viennent à moi
car j'ai plutôt grandi dans les terres
je suis originaire de provence et ça a
été une grande surprise pour ma famille
cette attraction pour l'océan depuis
tout petit donc aussi loin que je me
souvienne je pense que la première
personne qui a inspiré ma carrière fut
monsieur cousteau je me souviens de
cette cassette poser en bas de ma
bibliothèque
le champ des dauphins qui a dû passer
des dizaines et des dizaines de fois et
qui à ma permis pour la première fois de
poser mon regard sur ce grand bleu ce
grand bleu qui pour moi me paraît d'une
grande beauté rempli de choses mais qui
pour la majorité est passée vide est
assez effrayant même parfois alors j'ai
pour la première fois posé mes yeux sur
ce grand bleu et regarder de plus près
je me suis donc intéressé à ces tout
petits organismes que vous devez
connaître le phytoplancton pas plus
grand que la moitié de votre pouce et
pourtant ce phytoplancton et le début de
mon histoire il est de vie de votre
histoire et les débuts de notre histoire
c'est tout petits organismes
microscopiques sont responsables de plus
de 50% de l'oxygène présent dans notre
atmosphère
cinquante pour cent mille sept cent
millions d'arbres l'équivalent d'accord
de la forêt amazonienne
ni plus ni moins ce phytoplancton vous
permet de prendre une respiration sur
deux aujourd'hui si vous pouvez vous
sentir aussi à l'aise prendre votre
respiration comme il l'entend
ces textes sugen vient de l'océan cet
oxygène vient du phytoplancton
alors pourquoi je vous parle du
phytoplancton car celui ci est mangée
par le krill qui lui même est mangée par
les baleines
nous y voilà les baleines ce fut donc la
première fois que j'ai posé mes yeux sur
ces grands gérants et que j'ai compris
qu'en protégeant ses populations
je pourrais aider à relever les grands
défis environnementaux de demain de
cette première découverte je me suis
donc lancé avec pour idée première de
devenir cétologue un grand beau
cétologue qu'est ce que c'est alors je
me souviens au collège au lycée lorsque
vous posez la question
charlotte tu veux faire quoi quand tu
seras grande cétologue je veux étudier
les baleines dans l'océan pacifique
c'était très très précis on pas souvent
regardés avec des gros yeux décourager
car je pensais ça c'est la première
pensée que je veux partager avec vous
que les métiers de demain n'existe pas
aujourd'hui et que je pense aussi que
les gens qui réalisent leur métier par
passion ne peuvent que de venir des gens
qui excellent dans leurs compétences
lorsqu'on réalise quelque chose avec
passion alors de mon caractère de ma
détermination et de cette passion j'ai
poursuivi mon bout de chemin
je suis donc parti en sport études
plongée puis dans une institution c'est
à nos graphiques et commencer a parcouru
le monde le vietnam l'espagne et puis
l'irlande l'irlande
un objectif qui pour moi était de taille
car comme j'ai pu vous l'expliquer
cétologue c'est pas courant
un seul masters au monde propose de
devenir cétologue et ils demandent des
tests d'entrée très très rigoureux et
donc un anglais parfait d'où ma conquête
vers l'irlande pour améliorer cet
anglais et donc j'ai pu assister à un
grand séminaire européen sur les cétacés
une opportunité pour moi enfin de
pouvoir rencontrer les personnes qui me
faisait tant rêver depuis des années de
pouvoir enfin poser des questions et
neupro j'étais moi même
dans un futur très proche nous voilà
donc en face de ces étudiants de ces
enseignants est la la déception une très
grande déception car je me rend compte
finalement que le discours que l'on me
porte n'est pas dans mes attentes par
rapport à mon métier je me rends compte
que ce dont on me parle ce sont des
choses très pointilleuse des gens qui
passent de nombreuses heures dans des
laboratoires à scruter des choses
minuscules et moi je veux être en action
je vais être sur le terrain je vais
faire changer les choses je veux sauver
le monde
alors je me retrouve face à une vraie
déception et je me retrouve pas surtout
à une prise de conscience
les gens que j'ai en face de moi me
parle d'une recherche fondamentale alors
que moi je décide de faire de la
recherche appliquée finalement ce master
que j'ai longtemps convoité n'est plus
au goût du jour
je décide donc de poursuivre mon chemin
sur mesure de m'envoler pour l'île de la
réunion
et puis d'atterrir ici en polynésie
française il ya maintenant sept ans
j'arrive donc ici ou fenoyl et
subitement je ressens un sentiment qui
n'a des gars je ressens vraiment une
atmosphère qui est inspirante et
finalement tous ces rêves que j'ai
peuvent enfin prendre réalité ce projet
professionnel que je me tue à expliquer
autour de moi au quotidien n'a plus
besoin d'être expliquée
les choses vont d'elle-même
naturellement je finis donc mes études
ici et décide d'aller sur l'île d'en
face moulé à finir pour mon stage de fin
d'études
j'en approche du grand moment la
première rencontre avec ces grands
gérants
on m'appelle en effet un appel plutôt
inattendu et on me propose de remplacer
un guide naturaliste pour la journée
donc bien évidemment je saisis cette
opportunité je demande en quoi consiste
mon rôle à bord de ce bateau
charlotte c'est très simple tu vas
devoir informer les gens sur ces animaux
tu vas devoir partager des informations
leur expliquer pourquoi ces cétacés sont
présents dans nos zones qui sont ces
balles et nab
une opportunité incroyable j'embarque
donc le grand jour
on sort de la passe et nous voilà en
face de la baie d'opunohu on voit au
loin un souffle une baleine à bosse ces
grands géants sont enfin là tout proche
le capitaine me fait signe je m'approche
de lui et il m'a dit qu'il ya des
animaux et que je vais devoir me merger
grande surprise car c'était pas du tout
aux programmes
alors je décide de prendre les choses
dans l'ain fait un petit groupe de sept
personnes
les prépare un petit briefing de
sécurité et et c'est moi même de me
préparer à cette première grande
immersion à cette première rencontre je
vous propose ce soir de vous immerger
pour la première fois un des côtés et
d'entendre ma première rencontre je vous
invite donc à fermer les yeux à vous
concentrer sur le moment présent et à
écouter pleinement ce qui vous attend
[Musique]
voilà ce que j'ai entendu pour la
première fois alors je ne les ai pas vus
ces baleines il s'agit d'un mâle
chanteur qui était au loin mais qui
littéralement pour les gens qui ont pu
vivre cette expérience vous transporte
vous travers vous fait vibrer l'estomac
puis la cage thoracique
c'est impossible de rester sans aucune
émotion face un chant aussi puissant le
cachalot qui est d'ailleurs un cétacé
est connu pour avoir le champ le plus
puissant du règne animal
nous voilà donc toujours dans l'eau à
écouter ce sont fascinants et ma main
droite qui se sert et qui se sert car
j'avais un petit papier sur ma droite je
m'en souviens qu'ils me serrait la main
très fort alors je me tourne vers lui et
là qu'est ce que je vois des larmes et
des larmes qui coulaient dans son masque
alors vous vous imaginez bien l'émotion
qui m'a transmise moi même je me suis
retrouvé bouleversé on décide donc de
remonter sur le bateau
et là les gens sont éblouis par la
rencontre que l'on vient de vivre et les
questions arrivent
charlotte qui sont ces animaux quelle
espèce a vendu l'occasion d'écouter
pourquoi les baleines à bosse viennent
ici en polynésie chaque année alors je
m'exécute du répond à ces questions et
je me rend compte finalement que le
monde pose beaucoup de questions qui
restent sans réponse ici donc première
réflexion
une rencontre qui reste sans voix qui
m'a transporté et me donne envie de
vivre une seconde rencontre l'occasion
se présente à moi quelques mois plus
tard où je fais la rencontre de glu
alors ce bel et non que vous voyez sur
la photo est donc ma deuxième rencontre
une rencontre paraît rempli d'émotions
on s'immerge à l'eau avec un petit
groupe de personnes rencontrent beaucoup
plus intimiste beaucoup plus en accord
avec ma
philosophie on vit un moment vraiment
sans précédent une maman qui est posée
sur le fond qui se reposent en fin de
saison et un baleineau lui rempli
d'énergie qui vient à la rencontre qui
est curieux d'où son nom glu qui inspire
ni plus ni moins la proximité à mes
palmes
car il le choléra n'est pas le mystère
allemands et ceux baleineau j'ai la
chance depuis quelques années de le
revoir revenir chaque année autour de
nos îles il est donc maintenant presque
en âge de se reproduire
il a cinq ans il mesure donc presque 13
14 mètres et ils fréquentent donc
toujours no 1 on remonte sur le bateau
et la légion de cette émotion pareil me
sollicite me pose de nouveau des
questions mais charlotte comment on peut
faire du mal à ces animaux quelles sont
les menaces en polynésie française que
faisons nous pour ces animaux et
finalement glu a été la révélation a été
l'élément déclencheur un projet
professionnel que j'avais dans un coin
de ma tête depuis cinq ans la fondation
d'une association environnementale
j'ai donc en décembre 2010 est fondé
l'association océaniens qui est basée
sur l'île de moorea et qui oeuvrent pour
l'étude et la protection des cétacés
je rentre enfin dans le vif du sujet
dans l'action un des programmes phares
de notre association les vigies
sanctuaire l'unique programme en
polynésie qui a pour objectif de limiter
le risque de collision entre les
baleines à bosse et les navires à grande
vitesse et quelle satisfaction en fin de
saison avec notre équipe de se dire que
grâce à notre travail acharné
grâce à notre passion nous avons évité
plus de 100 collision voilà nous sommes
dans l'action
chaque jour ma passion ne cesse de
grandir et les études scientifiques
arrivent en renfort pour vraiment
concrétiser cette idée que j'ai dans un
coin de ma tête qui que ces grands
cétacés peuvent aujourd'hui nous aider à
relever les grands défis
environnementaux de demain
en effet souvenez vous de ce tout petit
phytoplancton en début de présentation
ce phytoplancton qui est responsable
d'une respire
a sion sur deux ce phytoplancton qui
vous amène cet oxygène au quotidien sa
croissance est tout simplement lié à la
présence et l état de bonne santé des
grands cétacés à travers le monde entier
en effet les déchets des grands cétacés
des baleines à bosse des baleines bleues
sont très riches en fer et en azote et
ses minéraux sont essentiels à la
croissance du phytoplancton cent
baleines se phytoplancton ne pourrait
donc pas grandir et se phytoplancton ne
pourrait donc pas assurer quelque chose
de tout simplement vital notre oxygène
dans notre atmosphère
deuxième grande découverte toute récente
y a pas plus de six mois on découvre que
ces grands cétacés peuvent nous aider
aujourd'hui à combattre l'un des défis
environnementaux les plus colossal le
réchauffement climatique
on l'a abordé ensemble pendant la soirée
les baleines s'y ajoute en effet à même
titre qu'un arbre capable d'absorber du
solde
les baleines sont elles aussi capable
d'absorber ce co2 un arbre absorbe en
moyenne 33 kg de co2 par an une baleine
33 tonnes mille fois plus ces animaux
jouent donc un rôle crucial dans la
l'absorption de ces sondes
la grosse différence par rapport aux
arbres les arbres à leurs morts vont
rejeter ce co2 dans l'atmosphère alors
qu'une baleine à sa mort elle va flotter
quelques heures parfois quelques jours
en surface et plus de son poids va
couler au fond de nos océans va couler
au fond de nos océans et à mener une
ressource alimentaire pendant 100 ans
en effet ces baleines là vont être au
début
convoité par les plus grands charognards
les requins qui vont vraiment s'atteler
aux parties les plus charnues de
l'animal et ensuite des animaux que vous
connaissez beaucoup moins de minuscules
verts qui vont forer progressivement
chacun de ces
oh et qui vont donc avoir une ressource
alimentaire disponible pendant 100 ans
ce que j'aimerais partager avec vous ce
soir c'est donc un état d'esprit
différent
une philosophie d'appréhender cette
nature est une
un état d'esprit qui nous permettraient
aujourd'hui de relever les défis
environnementaux de demain
en effet les baleines ces grands géants
des océans ont une valeur intrinsèque
très forte elle mérite clairement de
vivre dans ces océans
mais ce nouvel état d'esprit nous montre
aujourd'hui en quoi leur présence dans
l'océan est vital en quoi sans elle
nos océans ne peuvent pas être sain et
en quoi ces animaux peuvent nous
permettre d'avoir une planète plus
durable je suis donc convaincu que ces
animaux peuvent aujourd'hui nous aider à
relancer le grand défis environnementaux
et je suis donc convaincu que les
baleines pourraient peut-être sauvé le
monde mal aux doigts tous
[Applaudissements]